Every day,
youtube receives over 2 billion views.
Imagine if just 1% of those
views inspired people to do good.
Now imagine if one penny was
donated for each of those fuse.
Enter the jubilee project.
For every video we make,
we recruit sponsors to donate a penny
for each view the video receives.
So by simply watching the video,
you're not only learning about the issue,
but also helping to
raise money for a cause.
But we can't stop there.
Our vision is to create an online hub for
nonprofit organizations to raise funds,
spread awareness, and share best practices
through their own inspiring videos.
Verizon's $5,000 grants.
We'll make the realization of our vision
possible and through their wireless
technology people around the world,
we'll be able to stream these videos,
raise money for nonprofit organizations,
and make a lasting impact
around the world. After all,
did you believe project beliefs
that doing good is contagious?